hello everyone and welcome to another
game from the magnus carlson chester the
one
well one of the games that we said that
we were gonna cover as i didn't have
time to do it yesterday i was returning
from my vacation uh it's
a game from the blitz section uh so as
you know
in the rapid section uh section one game
was won by magnus one
one game was won by hikaru two of the
games were drawn and now this is the
first game of the
of the blitz section really a really an
awesome game so uh let's check it out
the really really interesting stuff
so uh e4 by hikaru we have e5 and
again of course we go for the berlin we
have knight to c6 bishop to b5 and the
knight to f6 so the berlin is on the
board
d3 and now bishop to c5 uh so the line
we've seen even in armageddon bishop
captures captures and knight b
to d2 we have castles and h3 but now
uh we we do have uh in uh knight to c4
instead of that
knight to f1 line that we we saw in
armageddon so knights the d7 and now
knight to c4 going after the e5 pawn
but this is only uh imaginary as the
magnus goes a5 says uh you're welcome to
go
go have a pawn uh because if you indeed
go for the pawn then you run into this
trick uh threatening checkmate and the
winning of the night so
nothing really special well not the
night but you have you have won some
material
so after a5 we have g4 by hikaru now
with ideas of
later on shifting the knight over to df5
square it's now very
nicely protected and rooked e8 by magnus
and
i forgot to mention uh here after knight
the c4 a5 is a new move in the position
so already as of move
8 we have a completely new game so let's
see what happens rookie 8 and the g4 now
like we mentioned not g3 uh we have rook
to e8 now defending the e5 pawn
and rook the g1 so hikaru going full
full aggressive mode preparing h4 g5 and
so on
magnus continues with a4 later on he can
play a3 to create weaknesses on the
queen side even
either weaken the dark squares or force
a capture which will
ruin white's pawn structure and here
knight the e3 now
this knight can come to f5 and unless
magnus wants to allow this
or if he doesn't want to weaken his uh
king side by playing such a move like g6
then he
has to give up the bishop pair and
eliminate the knight on e3 which he does
we have bishop captures bishop captures
and now knight to f8 the knight can now
come to g6 to e6 and then to d4
depending on what white plays so here
hikaru goes h4
now he says i'm gonna start pushing on
the king side and i'm gonna keep my king
in the middle of the board which is very
interesting as in this line of the
berlin it is possible to do this so
queen d6 by magnus and now queen to d2
just nicely developing
we have c5 now with firm grip on the d4
square and also at some point c4 can be
played
to put more pressure on the center of
the board the white king is still in the
center so you might
want to open up the position with h5 by
hikaru
and now b5 advancing the queen side even
further and now knight to h4 now this
knight is coming to f5
and first magnus goes queen to c6 he
doesn't want knight to f5 to come with
an attack on the queen and also he's
preparing c4
so in case white captures you can always
eliminate the e4 pawn so knight to f5 as
planned and now
c4 saying i'm not worried about anything
here on the king side
we have queen to b4 by hikaru now with
some ideas of 97
czech forking the king and the queen if
this happens magnus might
have to give up the rook and here magnus
plays a3 so what's
actually happening here can you play
knight to the e7 here
well you can but it's not really good
for white because here magnus gladly
gives up the exchange and after queen
captures then go a captures on b2 and
here y just completely
falls apart rook b1 captures on d3 not
much
you can do here captures queen here
there is no
there's no way for you to uh to even try
and save the rook
so after a3 we have b3 by hikaru and
now comes c captures on d3 here magnus
like we said hikaru's king
is in the center of the board of course
magnus wants to open up the center
see captures on d3 and now queen to c2
with some ideas of queen to b2
pushing the rook away maybe grabbing the
a2 pawn maybe creating a past a2 pawn
a lot of ideas are possible here so h6
by hikaru he says okay you do your thing
i'm gonna do my thing
and now puts pressure on the g7 point we
have g6
and now not immediately going for any
knight to e7 check ideas but first
rook to c1 first improving the position
of the rook he doesn't care about uh
queen captures on a2 because queen
captures on a2
is interesting but in a blitz game
very very hard to calculate for example
if queen captures an a2
then knight the e7 check king to h8 and
now
bishop to g5 this is incredible stuff
uh for uh preparing bishop to f6
checkmate and it's very hard for black
to stop this for example if you play
rook to a6 then comes queen captures on
b5
now with threats of sacrificing the
queen and then delivering bishop to f6
checkmate so all in all black would
probably have to give up the exchange
here
white would be better and we would have
a very very complicated game
as both players are very low on the
clock so here after rook the c1 magnus
doesn't go for the eight upon magnus
instead goes for the d3 pawn
uh leaving hikaru open with the exact
same idea here you can go like a
97 checking here and bishop g5 with the
idea of the
of the same pattern uh but uh like i
said it's a blitz game uh
finding this queen captures on b5 uh is
no longer possible
as the queen now guards this but it
would still be interesting for example
you can
if rook to a6 guarding f6 you can play
rook to g3
try to get the queen away from the
defense of the b5 pawn and so on
uh but before doing that after this
queen captures on d3
hikaru goes rook to d1 he first puts the
rook to
a much more open file not much more open
it's the only open file between c and d
uh queen to c2 and only now not knight
to e7 which is very interesting but
knight the g7 here hikaru notices
that the rook actually has no squares
this entire file is covered by the white
rook
this is covered by the queen and these
two squares are covered by the knight
so you might go rook to e6 but then the
knight just gobbles it up and
then bishop comes into play which is of
course possible to play
uh but there is one even better move
here i'm not gonna ask you to find it
because it's a
it's such a disgusting engine line that
i don't think i should even show it
but i know now that i've mentioned it
you guys are incredibly interested in
show us this sorcery i mean and i will
show it to you so here
uh the disgusting engine line is bishop
to e6
point is that after knight captures rook
and the rook captures
let's say queen captures an e5 going
after the e5 pawn
now you have c6 attacking the queen and
now
well uh you have to do something yes you
are up the exchange but the district is
doing nothing
you can no longer castle if black
eliminates this there's a pass pawn
so you could do queen captures on e5
threatening checkmate but now the whole
point
becomes obvious now black has the
incredible queen captures on d1
this is just beautiful stuff deflecting
the king to the d1 square
and now uh this will will happen so the
only move is king captures on d1
now bishop captures on b3 with check a
captures and now
capturing the queen uh leaving uh well
the material on the board is now
completely equal it's a rook and bishop
against the rook and knight with black
having this past pawn
is it a weakness or a strength you know
time would tell but uh
yeah none of this ever happened i just
want to show you this disgusting engine
line
so bishop to e6 incredible stuff but for
a blitz game
not very likely to to spot it so bishop
to b7 was played by magnus but now
hikaru just gobbles up the rook we have
knight captures rook captures and f3 by
hikaru
so he's now of the exchange he
strengthens the e and the g for pawns
and he wants to bring the rook into the
game
somehow so queen captures on a2 now
magnus goes after the
pawn creates a past a2 pawn which you
can now push and now
rook to d2 queen captures and b5 is also
very nice
just threatening that bishop but first
hikaru again improves his position rook
to d2
and gets the rook to a much more active
square queen to b1 checked by magnus
with king to f2 defending the rook and
also attacking carlson's queen
and here carlson goes a2 now saying okay
if you capture then i just bring another
queen into the game everything is
everything is fine here
so instead he carl goes queen to c3 he
defends the queening square now with
the queen and the rook and now magnus
has to figure out how to play this and
it's not easy finding a good move for
black
all of your pieces are tied down uh it
doesn't seem like you have a very active
plan
uh so here uh well for the lack of a
better move and low on time
magnus played rook to a8 he prepares a1
which seems to be winning on the spot
however it's not it's actually hikaru
who's winning at the spot so
pause the video here and figure out why
rook t8 was such a mistake while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
the rook on e8 was actually defending
black from being checkmated and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's
uh none other than rook captures on b1
now this works because after this
bringing another queen into the game uh
he carl plays queen captures on e5 and
now there is nothing more to be done
here and it was in this position i move
31 that
magnus carlsen resigns the game as the
rook from here was guarding the e5 pawn
and now there is no defending checkmate
and even though you could prolong the
game a few moves magnus quickly
spots that it's impossible to defend
because after knight the e6 defending
checkmate
you have bishop to d4 now threatening
rook to queen to h8 to checkmate of
course if
the capture happens then the knight no
longer guards the g7 square
so king to f8 would have to be played
and now of course queen h8
check king to e7 and bishop to f6
checkmate now as the rook covers these
squares
and the queen of course covers these
squares and also guards the bishop
so really really incredible stuff none
of this happened after queen captures on
e5
magnus resigned and he car won the first
game of the blitz section
which was simply incredible because
magnu because hikarna only needed a draw
to win the match and win the entire
thing uh but magnus was able to
retaliate
in the second game of the blitz force
armageddon and then get a draw with the
black pieces in armageddon like we've
seen in yesterday's video
in case you haven't seen that video do
check it out wild wild game i will put a
link to it
the first thing you will see in the
description below will be a link to that
game
so this is the last and final video
we'll be showing from the magnus carlson
chester we are of course returning to to
other stuff i have some
very nice lila videos some very nice uh
the good stuff videos of paul morphy
and some other suggestions you guys have
suggested uh
during this entire event so uh that's
the game that's
uh the entire coverage i do hope you
enjoyed this game and this short
coverage i've made of this uh
well event uh i would like to thank ken
castales
to christopher paran uh paul anderson
and the seven lucas
barcudarian for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh not continuing the coverage of this
but rather continuing the good stuff
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
do join us in the
alicia's uh uh friday arenas that uh
the links to those will also be in the
description below see you soon